to put in perspective what we saw last
night as well as over the weekend with
the pro football hall of fame class
gonna have busts in the same room as
this man from
nbc sports tony dungy how are you tony
hey rich doing great thanks how are you
i am doing fine
let's get right into it what did todd
bowles
do to that offense last night what what
did he cook up
that uh was so remarkable well there
were two things really i think he
learned a lot from that first time
around uh where they said hey we're
going to be pressure defense and we're
going to get after these receivers
and a lot of balls went over the top and
he came in and said we're not going to
have that happen they're going to have
to make 10 or 12 play drives
and then when they get in the red zone
they're going to have to execute so they
played a different style played their
safeties a little deeper played the
corners off
and made them throw a lot of balls and
then i think the second thing that he
understood todd did was
that because of the injuries to the
chief's offensive line
particularly eric fisher the left tackle
went out with the achilles
and that really forced three moves so
you had three
backup players playing the left tackle
right tackle and right guard
because of the shifting they had to do
and he knew his guys could get after him
so they played a little more
conservatively than the bucks normally
do
but it was really really masterful they
did a great job in the red zone they did
a great job on third down of just
not allowing the chiefs to get deep
and and make plays over the top and
were you surprised that the chief seemed
to um
just only use five men to protect
mahomes last night were you surprised
and it becomes harder if you
if you don't because how are you going
to do it travis kelsey is your
you know your biggest threat so if you
use him to chip and stay in you're
taking a big guy out of the passing game
do you put another tight end in to help
block so kelsey can get out but then
you're taking
you know uh hardman or tyreek hill off
the field so
it just was difficult and i think they
thought mahomes mobility
would keep tampa you know at bay and it
did
a little bit in the first quarter in the
first half patrick was scrambling making
plays
out of the pocket but i thought tampa
did a great job of being patient saying
hey these 12-yard scrambles these
10-yard runs aren't going to hurt us
and they they frustrated kansas city
well i mean and it is just a
a team effort and we could talk about
shaq barrett and jason pierre-paul
and you know vida veya and domic and sue
being
you know the guys who who provided that
rush
with just four sets of hands in the dirt
but how special is this
devon white kid tony dungy you know i
saw him play
uh early in the year and it reminded me
of seeing derek brooks
just sidelined the sideline instincts
around the ball
tip balls fumbles interceptions you know
with that speed
uh being there and we broadcast their
game nbc had their game against
washington
right and you know the coaches everybody
was telling us devon was out
oh you know next man up and and he's a
great player but
you know we'll be okay but you saw when
he went
back in the lineup against new orleans
against green bay and then yesterday
what a difference he makes uh he's a
special player tony dungy here
on the rich eisen show um and you know
that
this could be excuse making or what have
you but um
andy reid coaching under the
circumstances of his son britt
having been involved in an accident that
does appear to have involved alcohol
and there's a child uh in the hospital
based on that i how do you
block that stuff out during the super
bowl well you can't we will never know
the impact that i know
andy doesn't want to make excuses and
he's not going to say it but
obviously he's concerned about his son
he's concerned about the other family
um you can't just say hey i'm going to
take these
four hours and i'm not going to think
about it um
we don't function that way as humans so
i'm sure it had
had some type of impact but really the
big part of it to me was
that tampa learned a lot from that first
game i thought byron leftwich had
a great attack too for tom brady
and the way they went after the
linebackers who weren't a lot of balls
to mike evans and chris goblin up the
field
it was the tight ends in the backs and
they they didn't let
kansas city's rush be a fact that they
ran it uh
in passing situations they threw play
action they really kept them off balance
and i thought
leopards and bowles and bruce aaron they
had
a really good game plan where they
learned uh from the first game and
adjusted
let's talk a little bit about bruce
arians with you tony dungy
um 68 years of age football lifer
finally uh getting a chance to coach in
the super bowl as a head coach
for his own team and he becomes the
oldest
coach to win it um as a head coach
um what do you think he is thinking this
very
morning i know what he's thinking he's
enjoying it
and i was 53 52 i think when we won it
and i'm thinking gosh it'd be great to
go out
uh with this being your final
accomplishment maybe this is the time to
step away
and then you wake up in the morning and
you say no we could do this again so
that that's what he's thinking what do
we have to do to repeat
uh bruce did a masterful job here you
know
managing all the expectations bringing
in the different personalities hey
you've got to get gronk
involved in this you've got to get
antonio brown you've got to get leonard
fournette all these guys that they
that came together and he did a great
job of putting it together
and so i think he's thinking how can we
do this again
and then i want to put up a tweet from
ryan clark
a former player and a colleague of ours
in the uh in the industry
uh for espn thank you bruce arians for
showing the world that all three of your
coordinators can be black
your assistant head coach can be black
you can have two full-time women coaches
and be the best team in the world ba
you're a trailblazer
leadership doesn't have a look it has
been liked
over a hundred thousand times um
tony and i know you sent an open letter
to owners of the nfl and the
commissioner did you send an open letter
to the league on this very subject of
hiring
people of color and what's going on in
the league about it
yeah i did actually my bosses at nbc
wanted me to
write something for our website about
this
the whole hiring process and some of the
things that the shortcomings we had seen
and i
really didn't want to do it and then uh
jared bell
from usa today said i talked to him
about it he said well you should just
write a letter what would you say to an
owner if you could talk to someone right
now
and so that's the way i kind of
approached it and said hey look we're
right now we're cheating our fans we're
cheating
everybody involved with football because
we aren't utilizing everybody
kind of just what ryan was saying about
bruce and his staff
uh back in the 30s we thought we had a
great game
and we we weren't including everybody
and then we bring in
african-american players in the 40s and
people get to see
jim brown and marion motley and you know
ernie davis and and
bill willis and all these guys and and
our game is better
and then in the 60s and 70s we don't
have african-american quarterbacks and
we think we've got a great game
and it was a great game but we didn't
get to see
patrick mahomes and russell wilson and
lamar jackson
and doug williams and warren moon and
finally we do and it's a better game and
so
now you've got a situation where we're
not utilizing everybody
in terms of our head coaches and general
managers and
even coordinators and the game will be
better if we do
and that's what i said and and it kind
of echoes what ryan says
um you know we we have a great game but
it can be better
so i just want to hit on one particular
team for the moment
um and in the fact that uh the only
person of of color the jets did hire a
muslim the first muslim head coach
in in robert saleh uh the texans hired
david cully and i know that you were
part of uh i guess a committee of people
and
uh to advise in a way and of some sort
um but david culley
is a first-time head coach person of
color at age 65 and boy does he have
quite a situation uh on his hands with
desean watson not
really wanting to play there anymore how
would you counsel colley have you
reached out to him
at all on this front i have not i've
known david a long time and he'll do a
great job there
it is a difficult situation hey i met
desean watson when they played
uh he was at clemson and they played the
national championship game
in tampa against alabama yes and i did
the chapel service for clemson and i met
him then
and everybody at clemson talked about
how special this young man
is and was at the time everybody raved
about it and then he goes to houston and
he endears himself to the community
there his fir
his first game check he ever got he gave
to the cafeteria workers that were
displaced by hurricane harvey
and everybody talks about what a special
young man is what a joy to be around
and for him to say he doesn't want to
play there something happened
uh i don't know what but something that
they've got to get fixed
and hopefully david culley can fix that
but uh
i'll say this knowing desean watson just
a little bit that i've known him over
the last four or five years
he's not the type of person to to just
on a whim say well i didn't like this
or i didn't get my way in that so i'm
out of here
no one that knows him would say that so
somehow those fences have to be mended
and hopefully david can do that tony
dungy here on the rich eisen show so
much to talk to you about
um let's talk about who got in the hall
of fame class
first things first did you ever cover
drew pearson did that ever happen were
you lined up i did
yes yes i did my first uh recollection
of drew pearson i was a
freshman at the university of minnesota
and that
the hail mary game and i'm watching on
tv
and uh you know rooting for the vikings
because i'm going to the university of
minnesota
and i'm screaming he pushed off he
pushed off that's offensive passing
appears how can you not call that
and they uh they go in and win and then
uh four years later
yeah i'm covering him and i'm playing
safety and trying to make some tackles
on him in the super bowl
how'd that work but uh not not great for
me he's a great player
and really really a clutch guy clutch
performer and
well-deserved honor kind of delayed for
him like it was for my teammate donnie
shell
uh guys who were special in the 70s uh
and 80s and and just now getting
recognized and then
finally the call for for john lynch uh
look
tony i listen to warren sat when he
talks
uh for various reasons because he knows
what he's talking about and i i dare not
not pay attention to warren but he told
me many times
that the defense with him and brooks was
essentially built to funnel
everything to john lynch was that the
case from back in the day
john was a great player in that position
they have to do a lot and a lot
you know guys have been in that position
donnie shell bob sanders and john lynch
you know they've made a ton of plays i
was just
i was on the selection committee for the
first time this year rich and it was so
tough trying to
vote and be impartial when i had uh john
lynch peyton manning who was going to
make it obviously
rondae barber who i think deserves to be
in reggie wayne
and so you know you're making cases for
all these guys and then you have to vote
and they said okay we're going to
eliminate five guys who do you want to
leave out then we're going to eliminate
five
more and it was hard but uh john
played a very very difficult position to
play he played it well
he's in the uh ring of honor for two
different teams he made multiple pro
bowls for two different teams
uh he was a great player and a great
person what did you
what what do you remember the first time
you saw him when you you got him
tony well the first time i saw him uh
we were trying to draft him danny green
i was on denny's staff in minnesota then
he had coached him in college that he'll
be perfect for us
tampa beat us to the punch he's in tampa
so i played against him a couple of
times
and then i get the job there and he and
warren and derek are there and i brought
them all in one at a time and sat him
down i said warren you are going to be
joe green in this
defense derek you are jack hamm
john you're donnie shell and you're
going to go to multiple pro bowls i know
that
but we can win a championship if you
guys are the leaders and they they took
that on themselves and they led we
didn't get to the super bowl while i was
there but they certainly got to one and
were one of the best defenses of all
time and and those three guys were the
key
you must have had them at hello with
that tony that uh
you're you're you're mean joe green a
warren i mean that is
that i mean that you you probably got
their attention right on the spot
saying that no i showed them the 1975
steeler playbook
and now it's 1996 so it's 20 20 years
later but i showed him the playbook i
said nothing is going to change here's
this what jackham his his rules for weak
side linebacker derek this is going to
be written down for you
john the strong safety rules and cover 2
this is for you
and you guys this is tailor-made for you
and they they made me look like a
prophet
now and then of course you know i saved
the best for last with you tony
uh tony dungy here on the rich eisen
show can you give me
one peyton manning story that sums it
all up
that sums it all up as to who he is what
he stood for
what he did for the team uh type of
person
is there something that you could
express uh now that he is
in the hall i'll give you two stories
please really
tell everything about peyton manning
number one we're getting ready for the
super bowl
against uh the bears he watches
every game every regular season game for
the last two years
he has jim sorgy watch the pregame i
mean the
preseason games for guys who weren't
even on the team anymore in case they
did something in the preseason that they
didn't show the regular season they
might do against us
so he's preparing like mad and then
we're up in in
indy still we haven't even gone to miami
and he says
i'm looking at the 14-day forecast and
it says it might rain we ought to
practice with wet balls
i'm like are you crazy what are we gonna
practice with wet balls for two weeks
before the game
well because he's so that that way
we practice with wet balls and don't you
know it rain the whole game
but that's his level of preparation i'm
going to watch all the tape but i'm even
going to be watching the weather
so that talks about his preparation but
his
desire to help everybody be better the
greatest story i tell about peyton
my last year coaching was 2008 he's
already won a super bowl he's been
three time mvp we draft a receiver
anthony gonzalez from ohio
state ohio state is goes to school
all the way through june so anthony
can't be in our off-season program
peyton on his own two days a week
after we would get done he'd get in his
car drive three hours to columbus ohio
take the playbook with him go over the
playbook for an hour with anthony throw
for an hour
and then drive back eight hours twice a
week to help anthony gonzalez learn the
playbook
and that that's peyton manning he wanted
to make his teammates better he wanted
to win he wanted to prepare
uh but he's a special special person and
obviously he's known for his audibling
tony and uh but the guy who you know
is known for changing a play or living
by
the moment in that regard is somebody as
you point out wants to be as prepared
and as scripted as possible so the fact
that you
and david baker and his family was able
to surprise him
for being told that he's going in the
hall of fame that can you walk me
through that that had to be like
secret top secret high level stuff to
actually pull that one off
so top secret and it was funny um
because david baker
talked to his wife ashley and said what
can we do what would he like how could
we best
get this to him and she said well he
would love to have
all of his coaches everybody who's kind
of played a role in this
you know be part of it and him hearing
that would be special to him
so the hall of fame contacted everybody
started with his high school coach and
went all the way through all the coaches
that it had
and i think five of us were able to fly
to denver
and the other guys were on on video
but we flew to denver they told peyton
he was going to be taping one of those
peyton's places
segments in the stadium and then they
had us come out the tunnel
and uh fulmer his college coach said we
we're placing bets in the tunnel how
long is it going to take him his back
was to us
and we we settled on the over under was
three seconds
but we walked out and we didn't even uh
david kudkov didn't hit the end zone
before he turned around what's going on
here
and it was like he had eyes in the back
of his head uh but he was
very surprised he knew something was up
but he didn't know what it was and it
was a great thrill to have all of his
coaches speak to him his high school
coach i think is in his 80s
and he spoke over video and it was just
it was fantastic
so i hope you took the under the all the
coaches took the opponent
he'll know before before we even get out
there this is
something is going to happen so it was
great and then david baker came out
after us
with the announcement and it was really
neat yeah i just
uh to let you go here tony we talked
into troy
earlier on and he was talking about you
know drew pearson getting in and how
david baker and the
the president of the hall of fame in
canton and what an incredible job he's
doing to make these moments special
which is important these days you know
you got to get videos and things like
that out there you've gotta you've gotta
you know be viral in this day and age if
you can to be relevant
um and man i just love what he's doing
and we're remarking
he he is the largest man to ever sneak
up successfully on somebody in the
history of people
he really is a big man he's got a son
who was an offensive tackle
for usc for the americans for usc and
for the falcons
and sam is probably six five three
twenty and he still looks like a kid
next to his day
david's got to be 400 pounds and it's
just a heart of gold on a great man
tony thanks for the call really enjoy
our chats always
and there's so much to talk to you about
uh with what's going on in the nfl
over this weekend and obviously the hall
of fame that you you have
so many people that uh you're you're
close to so
i appreciate the time thank you thank
you rich always a
pleasure to be on with you thank you
right back at you that's tony dungy of
nbc go to nbcsports.com to check out his
open letter
to the nfl on the subject of minority uh
hiring and people of color hiring in the
nfl
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here